what did you learn about the nature of
politics and made you a more optimistic
or pessimistic you will be what politics
did teach me is that nothing is
impossible I grew up in the eastern part
of the current board of Mozambique when
the war of liberation started as a small
boy but I did see them all and at that
time it was unthinkable that the
gorillas will be able to defeat this
monolithic army of people with
helicopters cars big cars big guns and
but I lived to see the system collapse I
needed to see the people who are working
from a position of disadvantaged women
and then when i joined the opposition it
was unthinkable that one day President
Abbas government can be repeated I need
to see Mugabe being beaten in 2008 and I
lived to see myself actually winning an
election as a member of parliament of
course but I also see the puter I saw
the product side of politics politics
without rules is the recipes for
disaster for men a 44 for mankind there
must be rules and these rules don't have
to be necessarily written there must be
social rules that govern people they are
ma we must be this weekend with this
unfair but not that unfair and what I've
seen is that most politicians or the way
to get what they want irrespective of
how they get it so in the world of
politics specialist Bob in politics I
have seen people treat each other in the
most
speak above minus mr. Buchan still
president of your country was if I
remember correctly all of those freedom
fighters to turn Rhodesia into simple
fundamental free African country he
became president he still president
already for 56 years what did you learn
about the nature of power and I'm asking
you this because our first round table
conversation will be about what the
defect in our society and probably the
nature of power has something to do with
it George Orwell even animal farm was
very prophetic and you'd think that he
wrote that with is about a mite the the
way the animals fight we together get
power and the way they then treat each
other when the power has been the cotton
I think Mr Mugabe was a good fighter
444444 liberation and he did articulate
the things well unfortunately when he
when we got into independence he founded
the instruments of oppression used by
his predecessors and for him you're
going to use them to suppress dissent
and he was tempted to use these
instruments so what that teaches us
about the nature of power is that you
must limit it before a peasant gets the
second thing is that and ironically the
producing the British simply have led
this faster and it is that a good leader
in wartime is not necessarily a good
in peacetime fortunately the British had
their Chechen during the war and I am
related to lead of a better man
motivating his cuddle provide and fight
well a very difficult war I suppose to
see that men at the end of that war
losing any action and I think it was a
realization that you can be good in
blister in wartime you may not
necessarily be the best person to do the
reconstruction of the country and I
think the balance in maccabi they forgot